تطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا والطبيعه
التغيير الاستراتيجيه الذي ستحدثه
الدبابات التي سيزود بها الغرب كيف ومطالب
الغرب للجيش الاوكراني بتغيير تكتيكاته
كلها عناصر نناقشها بالتفصيل مع ضيفنا من
عمان الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء
فايز الدويري لواء فايز اذا ما بدانا
بالدبابات تشكيل هذه الفرق بهذا العدد
الذي جرى الاعلان عنه يضاف اليه مجموعه
ناقلات الجلد المدرعات وايضا التسليح
الاخر المستمر كل ذلك ما هو الفارق
الاستراتيجي الذي سيحدثها على الارض
يعني في هذه اللحظه لا يجوز لا يزال هناك
ضبابيه حول حقيقه الاعداء
الامر المقطوع به بريطانيا ستقدم 14 دبابه
امريكا ما بين 30 الى 50 دبابه المانيا
بالامس تسربت انباعا 150 دبابه و 150
دبابه وحلفاء الان الحديث الالماني عن
كتيبتين 14 دبابه اذا اخذنا بحرفيه الكلام
28 دبابه ومجمل المقدم من الدول التي
تمتلك هذا النوع من الدبابات بحدود 100
دبابه اذا نحن نتحدث عن تقريبا عن 158 الى
178 دبابه حسب التنظيم العالمي هذا يعادل
دبابات تشكيل فرقه لكن هنا لا يمكن الاخذ
بهذه المقارنه لماذا انا الحديث عن ثلاثه
انواع من الدبابه
تشالنجر
دبابات
الامريكيه والدبابه لبرد الان هذه
الدبابات لديها منظومات سيطره وقياده
وتقنيات مختلفه ولا يمكن ان تمزج في تشكيل
واحد اذا علينا ان ننظر عن طريقه
الاستقدام وطريقه الاستخدام التي اراها
انها ستشكل مجموعات قتال وليس على طريق
التنظيم العالم المعتمد اللواء والفرقه
هذه ستكون مجموعات واجب او ما يطلق عليها
تاسك فورس ما بين 30 و50 دبابه كل مجموعه
وبالتالي هذه تعمل
بقيادات مختلفه وبادارات مختلفه ومقاربات
مختلفه وبالتالي هنا نتحدث ان دور الدرع
في المعارك القادمه لا يشكر راس الحربه
بقدر ما هو تعزيز قدره الصنوف الاخرى
وبالتالي هذا يقود الى طبيعه ال- ال-
العملياتها في السياق الاستراتيجي بالامس
كنا نتحدث عن المبادئه الاستراتيجيه الان
نتحدث عن المبادئه التربويه وهي دون مستوى
الاستراتيجي لعدم وجود العدد الكافي من
النوع الواحد من الاليات يعني انها تبقى
اضافه نوعيه اضافيه يراد منها استخدامها
في مناطق مدن الجنوب وايضا همم
استعاده مناطق الجسر البري بين روسيا
والقرم التي احتلتها روسيا العام الماضي
حسب وزير الدفاع الامريكي هل هذه
التشكيلات معنى هو موجود اساسا بامكانه
بان همم يعطي مثل هذه النتائج المرجوه
يعني عندما يتحدث عن ااا عنق الزجاجه الذي
يربط خلصن بشبه جزيره القرم اعتقد في ظل
هذه الارقام انه متفائل جدا لماذا انا نحن
نتحدث عن اكثر من 120 كيلو متر المسافه من
نار الدنيا برد حتى مدخل شبه جزيره القرم
لكن لو تتحدث على سبيل المثال عن بعض
قطاعات جبروجيه او مثل ما اليوتيوب او غير
ذلك نعم نقول هو تحدث
بمقاربه تتناسب وحجم الاسلحه المقدمه لكن
هل هذا ما يقدم هو كل ما سيقدم ام هو دفعه
اولى على طريق تصعيد محمود في تزويد
السلاح اذا كان ذلك تعتبر دفعه اولى
وسيكون هناك
دفعات جديده الان نتحدث عن الارقام التي
تحدثنا عنها سابقا وتحدثنا عنه
ايضا اريد ان يعني على
المطالب الغربيه لاوكرانيا بتغيير تكتيكات
القتاليه ما هو المطلوب
حجم العقيد القتاليه الغربيه لا يفضل
الخوف في معارك الخنادق وفي معارك
الاستنزاف التي تمتص القدره القتاليه
للوحدات فبدل ان ادافع عن باخمس لاشهر
وافقد عشرات الالاف سواء من المقاتلين
والمعدات وحتى القوات المقابله تخسر لا في
العقيده القتاليه الغربيه انا ادافع ضمن
حدود امكانيه معينه وبالتالي افضل
الاحتفاظ بالقوه على الاحتفاظ بالارض فانا
هنا قد اقاتل لي قاع الخسائر ثم انسحب الى
مواقع المحاضره واستغل باك القوه من خلال
المناوره النار والحركه في مناطق اخرى قد
تكون مكافئه او اكثر قيمه هذا صلب العقيده
القتاليه الغربيه وبالتالي الاجانب
الامريكيين تحديدا يطالبون القاده
الاوكرانيين بالانتسال لهذا التوجه بان
هناك مناطق تعتبر خاسره رغوه غير مدافع
عنها بصوره جيده نعم تتخلى عن باك موت
ولكنك ستندفع باتجاه ماليود همم اليوتيوب
ولا على سبيل المثال اذا دعيني اقول هناك
فرق في الثقافه العسكريه واليه اداره
المعركه ما بين من درس في المعاهد
السوفياتيه والروسيه وبين من درس في
المعاهد الغربيه شكرا
على المشاركه معنا حدثنا من عمان